for centuries these two islands in the
South Pacific were home to Maori people
they call it aotearoa
the indigenous Maori population was
rooted in a sacred relationship with the
land and surrounding Waters
they organized Society in an intricate
system of tribes and sub-tribes
they flourished
but by the end of the 1800s roughly 60
percent of them were dead due to new
diseases displacement and War all caused
by Western colonizers who call the
islands New Zealand
over the course of several decades more
than 90 percent of collectively owned
Maori land had been taken by the British
crown they not only took the land but
they took a river that River meant
everything to us
there were hundreds of my own systems
that were taken we lost the language we
were last name
we've lost our way of life you can't
know one day at times
who am I
what am I
but today
something groundbreaking is happening
here
a kind of reparations or as they refer
to them in aotearoa settlements land and
cash settlements for Maori accompanied
by historic formal apologies from the
government another first this law
includes an apology our UE received 87
million dollars in cash from the crown
17 land blocks have been returned you
know with deeds and titles and 170
million dollars
peanuts it really is peanuts I'm here in
aoderoa to take a closer look at Maori
people's long fight for sovereignty over
their lands and all of the mixed
emotions and outcomes that come with it
I'm also here to explore how a similar
movement for a dress could gain more
steam in the United States for Native
Americans and black people descended
from those enslaved in America
Maori people have gotten the British
crown to recognize the harms of their
pillaging apologize and pay what can we
learn about reparations from their story
foreign
at the end of the 18th century about 100
000 Maori lived in aotearoa and were
part of various tribes still known today
as iwi and sub-tribes hapu
though they weren't functionally a
nation they controlled every corner of
the islands
but in the first half of the 19th
century Europeans began to arrive by
thousands of ships especially people
from England
far beyond the small settlement of
British missionaries already living
there
disputes to occur between the new
arrivals in Maori particularly around
youth of land
the settlers saw the land as property
something to be owned which was in
conflict with the Maori View
and there were new outside threats too
Maori learned that the French and other
westerners wanted their Lance
so they began signing this declaration
of independence in 1835.
rangatira or Maori Chiefs use the
document to make a firm statement to the
rest of the world that Authority within
aotearoa rested with them
the document declared hey fenua
rangatira which translates to an
independent state
with new nationhood they petitioned King
William IV for support and protection
and a few years later the British
government and Maori Chiefs saw the need
for another formal document
there were opportunities to both engage
further with the British crown as as
treaty Partners in in having a strategic
political but also trading partner
in 1840 more than 500 Maori Chiefs
signed this document
[Music]
with the British crown
is the foundational document at the
center of the story
its creation opened up the gateway to
the unlawful British colonization of the
islands
it's been vigorously debated because
there are Stark differences between the
Maori and English texts of the treaty
the Maori text says that the rangatira
have Tino rangatiratanga which
translates to Absolute authority over
their lands resources homes and Tonga or
treasured possessions
but the English text states that the
rangatira seed to her majesty the Queen
of England All rights and power of
sovereignty
those big differences One Vision saying
you see the exceeded 70 the other one's
saying actually you get to govern
yourselves and look after yourselves you
know that's quite fundamental really in
terms of how things rolled out across
our history within a Maori world view
within a Maori philosophy it's not
actually possible to suddenly decide to
give up that sovereignty to someone else
the British proceeded to assert control
over the islands after the treaty was
signed claiming that under British law
they had the power to set up a
government
they appointed a Governor William Hobson
and formally established aotearoa as a
colony by the end of 1840. they were
laying sales or purportedly in sales
where they engaged with perhaps one of
the hundred owners or you know 100
people that had rights to a piece of
land they'd engage with one person that
effectively would sell the entire block
where I'm from in wairo there's a really
big significant purchase of of land
which was framed as a sale and purchase
but my ancestors were told by the crown
purchase agent either you sell us this
land or we won't confiscate it
and so it's those kinds of coercive
practices which also resulted in
significant land loss
there was resistance of our people to
that happening conflict over land and
resource came to a head in 1860.
in the decades-long New Zealand Wars
Maori people battled to protect their
land but they were severely outnumbered
by British troops who killed more than 2
000 Maori
through the wars the British confiscated
massive amounts of land supported by a
new law that said the crown could seize
the land of anyone who had rebelled
against the queen
Modi were allowed to defend their claims
to land in court but mounting a defense
usually included prohibitively expensive
legal fees and travel costs
this land confiscation triggered a
breakdown of the Modi economic base and
disrupted the communal culture of Modi
identity
plus diseases that European colonizers
brought to aotearoa continued to kill
Modi in large numbers
in 1840 shortly after Europeans began
arriving by the shipload 80 000 Modi
lived on the islands by 1896 only 42 000
remained
meanwhile the Pacquiao population those
who were white or non-mowdy ballooned to
701 000 people
an estimated 88 of Maori lands were
taken
it wasn't until decades later that Maori
activists would force the British crown
to reckon with this history
as a child growing up
in the first 15 years of Our Lives for
me
was around how to be a pakiha everything
was geared up to how to talk like them
just let them
similar
by the 1950s New Zealand's government
had Rewritten the history of the Crown's
colonization into a Rosy story
one newspaper from the early 1900s
quoted a politician who said the Modis
had always been loyal to the British
Empire New Zealand was a country that
had never been conquered or annexed it
was a mutual agreement
there has been a real perpetuation of a
myth that you know New Zealand has great
race relations and often to treat your
waitangi is held up as the example of
that is is to say look we
negotiated the sovereignty by consent
but in practice
Maori has
used for more than a hundred years after
the Treaty of waitangi had been signed
for the first time in history a reigning
British monarch visitor Maori subject
Maori military men who fought for the
crown in both world wars were not given
the same benefits as pacquia after their
return
disparities became glaringly apparent by
the mid-century compared to Pacquiao
Modi had poor health outcomes like
double the child mortality rate they
were over five times more likely to be
incarcerated and both Maori men and
women had lower incomes than their
pacquiaoque counterparts
and in 1953 the crown introduced laws
that further forced some Modi to sell
their land
those laws along with World War II
helped incite a mass migration of Maori
from rural lands to cities
living in crisis was a whole experience
living in a white town you cannot hold
your prison go holy hell
I never experienced racism like that as
a young boy I wasn't too sure what the
hell was going on but I knew there was
something wrong
[Music]
thank you
I can't help but think about the
similarities here between how black
Americans and Native Americans were
treated in the United States around the
same time
many black Americans and Native
Americans enlisted and fought in World
War II
but upon their return from the war they
were shut out of benefits that were
extended to white Americans like home
loans and Educational Funding provided
by the GI Bill Black Americans were
segregated through redlining and the
benefits didn't extend to Native
Americans living on tribal lands
over time the compounding impacts of
racial discrimination in the U.S showed
up the same ways they did for Modi
populations with a higher infant
mortality rate black incarceration rate
that was just over five times higher and
much lower net worth
but by the 1960s with many Maori now
gathered in cities
they were better positioned to challenge
leadership
in America black people are treated very
much as colonized people because we're
used we're brutalized the police and our
community occupy our area our community
and the foreign group occupies territory
the Advent of Television helped Maori
tune into the black power movement and
the activism of Native Americans in the
United States if the people have to
stand up and demand and they have to
understand that they have a right in
America you had quite a few movies and
checkers that made the difference and
that was all through marching
members of the activist group natamatoa
channeled these lessons into their
protests they were part of a movement to
revitalize the Maori language Maori
which had been actively suppressed in
schools for decades
and later Natha matoa helped launch one
of the biggest protests in aotearoa
history the land March of 1975.
joined since early this morning by young
and old and in spite of rain which set
in late in the morning the march of
spirits are still high it's a huge
project a lot of our people Etsy didn't
support us they think we're a little bit
naive or a little bit nutty
the protest action needed someone who
could rally Maori together her name was
finna Koopa Fina Cooper was a respected
Maori Elder descended from the therarawa
iwi who dedicated her life to Maori land
rights and to the rights of Maori women
she was nearly 80 years old at the time
of the March we need somebody La death
that can reach to the heart in the minds
so we cut the face we need a slogan and
so we came up with a slogan Not one more
Acres of Maori Lane be sold
one more acre after all these 135 years
we have only 2 million Acres left
the March took 29 days and grew to
include 5 000 people they came from all
over the North and South Islands
and when they arrived at Parliament
marches presented a petition signed by
60 000 people that laid out their goals
they were here to establish new laws
from Maori Land Based on their own
cultural values communal ownership of
land within the tribe protest movements
anywhere in the world makes a difference
if you don't protest nothing will happen
and people will will think everything's
all right it's not all right the crown
long reluctant to acknowledge the harms
of its colonization was forced to
respond
they established the Treaty of white
Dengue Act of 1975 to investigate
contemporary breaches of the 1840 treaty
but it wasn't until after another decade
of protests that the Maori won the right
to give the investigating tribunal
retrospective powers
the ability to investigate grievances
going all the way back to 1840. while
this tribunal could only offer
recommendations for government action
it opened the door for a kind of
reparations
the government decided to create a
pathway to dozens of land and cash
settlements that are ongoing today I was
really excited about that
be able to do some more research for us
did to share our story for us to be able
to have these similar type of
conversation at last we can talk to each
other about it
unless we can have a voice we can sing
about I don't have a problem with that
in products it's just there seem to be
something not quite bright the
settlement was the right thing to do the
value of the settlement I think was
wrong
but when you think about it now
it's only a drop in the bucket
there are about 138 government
recognized ewe today and they all have
their own specific historical grievances
with the crown
as of 2022 there have been nearly 80
settlements passed into law
these claims generally work like this
ewe must register a historical claim
with the waitangi tribunal to have their
grievances heard and to proceed in the
settlement process
if their claims are deemed well founded
they can begin the process of direct
negotiation with the crown
after what can be years of back and
forth eventually they write the final
deed of settlement that both parties
sign
to receive the settlement assets ewe
must set up a governance entity that
administers the winds on behalf of the
community often putting the money
towards Business Development health and
education for the entire group not
checks to individuals
the list of what Maori are seeking is
long
it includes millions of dollars
apologies the return of land Waters
Fisheries minerals
and the restoration of theater Maori the
Maori language
and no two settlements or the experience
of negotiating them are the same
but many people look here so why
the first Evie to settle in 1995 as a
model for what settlements could be
as the first EU to settle they laid the
groundwork for all the settlements that
followed
in 1995 the crown recognized the
unlawful theft of more than a million
Acres of waikato lands in the 1860s and
settled with the ewe for 170 million
dollars
this was a time in this country where
settlements we knew it was against
public opinion it certainly was a
courageous move on the part of the
government at that time
Queen Elizabeth signed this treaty
settlement which to this day is one of
the largest sums of money given to an
ewe this is the first time the queen has
ever signed any law in public there was
the Pinnacle of all apologies
most apologies are given by the crown by
the government
in this instance it was the only
apology made by Queen Elizabeth II that
we were the only tribe to get that
formal apology
in a signed letter
from her is huge
because it was an admission of the of
their guilt
of their wrongdoing and their Injustice
the settlement was successful but also
controversial
for one the ewe was criticized for
signing with the crown just months after
dozens of ewe Nationwide rejected the
government's one billion dollar fiscal
cap on the settlements and the
settlement only provided the return of
around thirty thousand acres
it's a insignificant amount of land when
you compare with that which we lost
one big win was the therapa Air Force
Base which they developed into a
shopping district a move to bring them
economic independence
the settlement also included the 15
million dollar waikato tainui College
which has helped them invest in
education
anyone who want to do business in our
tribal area
and they'll come talk to us
We're undeniable now things have changed
in 2010 waikato tainui finalized another
settlement this time it was for the
longest river in New Zealand from which
the ewi takes its name the waikato river
we got an agreement that gave us equal
say
and anything that happened on the river
in the river around the river
so for me as a negotiator for Miami for
my tribe
it was the greatest honor of all the job
that we did
was was a minor compared to the hundreds
of our ancestors who died in the battles
for our land
for Who We Are
for our way of life
they paid a huge sacrifice
for us to sit in those offices and try
to get a deal with the government in
order to resolve our outstanding claims
against the crown
the settlements haven't been as large
and they've taken decades to negotiate
I'm here at natimaru's official
settlement ceremony
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
or representative from the crown
is going to deliver an official apology
the crown makes the following apology
to nothing
the crowns many breaches of titriti or
waitangi
left natimaru feeling like refugees in
their own Homeland
it's confiscation of half of the rohi of
natimaru
was indiscriminate
and unwarranted
the crown acknowledges that
it's imprisoned members of natimaru
assaulted the human rights of the people
residing there and forcibly removed many
inhabitants
destroyed and desecrated their homes and
sacred buildings
stole heirlooms the crown expresses
profound remorse
and apologizes
settlement included 30 million dollars
in cash the return of 17 Land Titles and
the right to purchase 36 Crown
properties including the dewera forest
I am humbled to have delivered these
words to you today
I know how many of you will be thinking
of those loved ones who were lost before
they had a chance
to hear the crown apologize for what's
wrong doing I pay tribute to your dupuna
[Music]
you lose your identity you lose
everything
so we have been in a process of
reclamation and rejuvenations and
revitalization
ultimately many maoris see the
settlements as an Avenue for empowerment
and restitution
but they don't ignore the issues Sami we
have expressed that they don't
necessarily believe the crown apology to
be genuine and it's something that the
crown does for their own benefit to
release themselves of
I don't know perhaps burden or guilt
over those historical breaches
ultimately the Ministers of the crown
get the final decision
on the level of quantum the level of
financial redress
you know what land Parcels might be
available to come back
what what we're giving away
in in likes of land water the air we
breathe
is is with billions
all stolen property should be returned
it's like a car it's a stolen car
your car was taken with everything in
the car everything taken then they kept
your car back with no motor in it
it's just the wheel you can't move it
you can't drive it
yeah yeah we want the whole car
today
aotearoa is 27 years into their
settlement process
for some these settlements have met
life-changing differences in business
opportunities and education
[Music]
in many categories like median household
income Maori outcomes have improved
but they still fall behind pakea
I see settlement as a
reparation
I think reparations are far too nicer
word
we can't embrace the cruelty the
injustice
the loss of life
this is about righting a wrong
we're talking about blood here
these kinds of complications are echoed
in the reparations debate in the United
States some people say that there's no
amount of money that could ever
compensate for slavery or for land loss
and people say that reparations would
further divide the United States but
what the Maori process shows us is that
you have to start with acknowledging the
past
an apology for slavery in the Jim Crow
laws
which for a century after emancipation
the Senate apologized for slavery and
Jim Crow in 2009 today the Senate were
unanimously make that apology but made
no mention of reparations
and while the U.S apologized to Native
Americans for acts of violence and
neglect
the statement was largely buried in the
back of a 2010 defense bill
even though aotearoa can't be an exact
model for the United States Maori have a
direct message for people in the U.S
the fight for reparations is worth it
y'all know it sounds that's like never
going to happen but truly
there comes a point where they have to
start to listen
the struggle might be long and full of
uncertainty
but if the U.S continues to push the
reparations debate forward people here
could gain land money better policies
and new Pathways to Healing just like
the Modi
[Music]
came before
[Music]